was the mother of all storms you could
drown standing up the wind was blowing
so so hard
my name is John Keller I'm a recon
marine also Katrina survivors
I went to the hospital to try to get
medication couldn't get that done I
paddled out to my mom's house now I'm
off from here to see if she was there
basically when I came back I hot-wired
two boats and shuttled everybody to the
landing zone that was on the bayou and I
got ever put up out in the helicopter
and the people who were really critical
we carried him up in the real chest to
the roof and we had a Coast Guard
helicopter the orange helicopter land on
the roof and we put him on the shuttle
in my way I said it like a little quick
prayer to God I said man if I take care
of these elderly people you make sure
you appoint somebody to take care of my
grandma but please don't have them
treating her like this
and that's what made me stay
I saw babies and old people floating in
the water and I guess by me going to
Iraq the first time it it made me numb
to it it just just it wasn't anybody I
knew it was sad it was sad but it I
wasn't all choked up to where I couldn't
function I mean I wasn't crying I'm
shedding tears I was just maybe I was
just like in and all like man we in
America how could this be happening